翻訳: Mari Arimitsu
校正: Hiroko Kawano
7.6パーセント
皆さん この数字 何の数字だと思いますか？
今年の春に とある民間企業が
７万人を対象に調査を行ったところ
約7.6パーセントが LGBTであるという
回答があったと
レズビアン・ゲイ・バイセクシュアル
トランスジェンダー
その４つの頭文字をとって LGBT —
いわゆるセクシュアル・マイノリティの
総称として使われる
この言葉なんですけれども
7.6パーセントといえば
日本の人口で言うと 約９百万人以上 —
神奈川県の人口よりも多い この数字を
もはやマイノリティと言えるのだろうか？
そんなことが最近では 議論されています
同じく今年の春 東京都の渋谷区では
同性カップルにもバートナーシップの
証明書を発行するという条例が可決された
そんな話題が注目を浴びました
そして同じく つい先日ですね
アメリカでは全ての州で同性婚が可能になった
そんなニュースが話題を呼びましたけれども
このように最近ではセクシュアリティに関する
ニュースが非常に多くなっていると思います
でも 同性婚がどうこうと言う前に
そもそも「性」って何なのか？
そこから少しお話ししたいと思います
もし「あなたの性別は何ですか？」
と聞かれたら
皆さんは何と答えますか？
例えば「男性です」—
じゃあ「何で男性なんですか？」
「やっぱり付いてるものが
付いてるからかなぁ」とか
「女性です」—
じゃあ「何で女性なんですか？」
「子供を産むことができるからかな？」
このように人というのは
性について語るとき
体の性　生物学的な性によってのみ
語ることが多いんじゃないかと思います
ただ 性というのは
そんなに単純なものではなくて
幾つかの要素に
分かれているんじゃないかと
その要素が組み合わさって
できているんじゃないかということで
今日は「性」を３つの要素に
分けて考えてみました
１つ目 「カラダの性」
これは例えば
XXなら女性 XYなら男性といった
染色体のお話だったり
内外生殖器のお話 —
生物学的な性ですね
もう一つは 「ココロの性」
これは性自認 ―
自分は男である 女である
といったような
ココロの性
そして最後 ―
「スキになる性」というのは性指向
対象の性がどちらに向くか？
この３つに分けて考えることが
できるんじゃないかと考えました
そして この３つの要素に
分けて考えた時に
どの要素にも 今まで考えていた
「男」「女」というのだけには
当てはまらない性もあるんじゃないかと
いう風に考えてみました
１つ目の「カラダの性」
性分化疾患という言葉を
皆さん聞いたことがございますか？
これは 「生物学的な性が
先天的に非典型的な特徴を持つ状態」
という風に言われるんですけれども
「何だろうな ちょっとそれ
よく分からないな」と思うんですが
どんなことがあるかというと
実は染色体が XXY であったりとか
XY なんだけれども
身体が女性化していたりとか
あとは 一つの体内に精巣・卵巣
両方の要素を持って生まれてくる —
そういった
約70種類以上もの症状を総括して
「性分化疾患」という言い方をします
これは 約1000 〜 2000人に１人いる
という風に言われているんですけれども
医学的には認められていても 社会的には
なかなか認められないということで
なかなか表に出てこない課題です
こう考えてみても
「男」「女」という風に
きっぱり いつも二分できるだけの話では
ないんじゃないかと
そして「ココロの性」—
これは 多くの人が
自分は「男だ」「女だ」と
思っていると思うんですけども
中には よく最近テレビなんかで見かける
色んなセクシュアリティの人が
いますけれども
そういう方を見ていると
100パーセント男とも女とも
言い切れない方たちっていうのも
いるんじゃないかな？
７割３割で男性かなとか
半々ぐらいかなとか
そういったゼロか百かとか
「男」か「女」かというよりも
もっとグラデーション —
「赤」か「白」かと言うなら
ピンク色でいらっしゃる方も
結構いらっしゃるんじゃないかなと
そして「スキになる性」は
聞いたことがあるかと思うんですけれども
異性が好きなのか 同性が好きなのか
それとも両方好きな
バイセクシュアルなのか
そう考えただけでも
性を３つの要素に分けて考えた時に
どの要素にも 今まで考えていた
「男」と「女」という
それ以外にも
考えられるんじゃないかということで
３X３X３＝27通りの性別が
あるんじゃないかという
仮説を立ててみたのが
この表になります
皆さん ご自身が何番か
ちょっと見つけてみてください
いわゆる一般的な女性というのは
身体が女性
そして心も女性で
男性が好きという２番
いわゆる一般的な男性というのは
身体が男性で「僕」と思っていて
女の子が好きという13番
では僕自身はどうだったか？
というと
僕は元々 身体は
女子として生まれてきました
だけど 小っちゃい時から
ずっと「僕」と思っていて
僕自身は女の子が好きなので
４番になります
ではレズビアンと何が違うの？
と言われると
身体が女性で 心も女性
そして女性が好きな１番がレズビアン
身体が男性で 男として
男性が好きな 14番がゲイ
そんな風に分けて考えることが
できるんじゃないか
じゃあ ゲイとレズビアンは
それだけなの？
ちょっとややこしいんですけれども
例えば僕みたいな状態 ―
身体は女で生まれてきました
でもずっと「僕」と思っていて
僕が男性を好きであると
実は身体と対象だけ見ると
異性なのかなと思うんですが
気持ちとしては
同性愛として男性が好き —
そういったこともあるんですね
こういう風に言うと 段々
ややこしくなってきてしまうんですけれど
別に これは27という数字だけが
全てと言うつもりはなくて
これだけ多様に考えられる性を
もう「男」と「女」という
２つの枠に押しはめて考えるのは
ちょっと窮屈なんじゃないかなということで
実は もう10年以上前
大学の卒業論文で書いた表になります
ちょっと 頭が
こんがらがってしまうと思うので
簡単に ここでクイズをしたいと思います
「クイズこの人は何番？」ということで
今から写真が何枚か出てくるので
この人が何番か当ててみてください
早速まいりましょう
はい この黄色いシャツを着ている
イケメンお兄ちゃん 何番だと思いますか？
彼はすごく仲良しなんですけれども
若い頃から自分でビジネスを立ち上げて
バリバリと仕事をしているんですが
そんな彼は 身体は女性です
そして 気持ちはずっと男性として
彼の場合は 好きになった方が好きですと
バイセクシュアルということ —
６番になります
次 はい
このオジさん２人
こちらの オジさまから
まいりましょう
このブルーのシャツのオジさま
彼の場合は身体は男性です
そして男性として男性が好きだ —
ゲイですね
では こちらの白いシャツの
オジさんはと言うと
身体は男性 そして気持ちも男性として
とっても女性が大好きな ―
ウチのお父さんです（笑）
よかった ここは笑ってもらえないと
ちょっと恥ずかしいんですけれども
自分の父親に「何番か」なんて
聞いたことはないんですけれども
普段の行動を見る限り
そうなんじゃないかなあと
「そして 僕も生まれていることだし」
と 言いたくなってしまうんですけど
実は ここに落とし穴があって
結婚してお子さんが
いらっしゃるからといって
異性愛かというと
それは違う
決して必ずしもそうとは
言えないんですね
結婚して 奥様もいて
お子さんもいらっしゃるけれども
実はゲイなんです —
またその逆も然り
そういった方も
沢山いらっしゃいます
日本では長らく
家庭を持つということが
１つ社会的な信頼を得る
ということでもあったので
本当は「ゲイなんです」
「レズビアンなんです」
もしくは「トランスジェンダーなんです」
という方も
実はそういった自分の気持ちを
押し殺して
世間体に合わせるために
結婚してお子さんを持って
家庭生活を営んでいる方も
本当は沢山いらっしゃる
「本当にそんな人いるの？」
と思うんですけれども
実は僕の友達のお父様も
ゲイなんですね
ただ僕の友達も まだ知りません
僕がこう言った活動をしているので
実は相談をされたことがあるんですけれども
意外と身近にいるんだなと
自分自身が驚いたことがありました
どんどんまいりましょう
はい ではこの２人 —
この２人はですね
２人とも 身体は女性
そして気持ちも女性として
女性が好きな
レズビアンのカップルです
日本では まだ同性婚というのは
できないんですが
せめてウェディングだけでも
挙げようよということで
今この同性カップルの結婚式で
ウェディング業界は
かなり盛り上がっています
そして この緑色のビブスを
着ているんですけれど
地元の新宿で ゴミ拾いのボランティアを
[私は] 10年位やっているんですが
そこによく来てくれる子なんですが
そんな彼は 身体は性分化疾患 —
元々 １つの体内に精巣と卵巣 —
女性と男性 両方の要素を持ち合わせて
生まれてきたそうです
もう 20歳を超えて 自身が男性であるという
性自認がしっかりとしてきたので
今では手術をして 男性として
社会生活を送っています
そして最後の１枚
このお姉さんは何番だと思いますか？
皆さん もはや口がポカーンという感じに
なっているかと思うんですけれども
最後の１枚です
このお姉さんは
なんと身体は女性です
そして女性として 男性が好きな
ウチのお姉ちゃんです（笑）
似てますか？
何でこの１枚を最後に
持ってきたかというとですね
大体こういう話をすると
「え じゃあお姉ちゃんは普通なんですか？」
と聞かれるんですね
ただ 何を以って「普通」
というか分かりませんが
月曜日から金曜日まで
会社で働いて
週末はネイルに
アロマにワインに
将来の夢は お嫁さんかどうかは
分かりませんけれども
でも 普通なほど普通の
私のお姉ちゃんでございますということで
皆さん 何問正解しましたでしょうか？
もはや どこからが何問とか
誰が何番とか
全然分からなくなっちゃったと思うんですが
別にこれは 決してそういうことを
言いたかったわけではなくて
何が言いたかったかというと
セクシュアリティというのは —
「目に見えない」
セクシュアル・マイノリティを考える時に
１つ これがキーワード
なんじゃないかなと思っています
例えば車椅子があって
車椅子の方の前に段差があれば
それは 「ちょっと大変なのかな？」
「手伝うこともできるかな？」
という風に思うんですけれども
セクシャリティというのは
目に見えないので
言わない限りは分からない
自己申告制なんですね
なので 例えば今まで
そんな人会ったことないよと
はっきりおっしゃる方も
いらっしゃいますけれども
それは もしかしたら
会ったことがないんじゃなくて
気付かなかっただけなんじゃないかな？
当事者としては いないのではなくて
言えない事実がある
そういった現実があると
それだけなんですね
なので 約10年前 僕自身が
性同一性障害であるという
カミングアウト本を出した時に
本当に北海道から沖縄から
全国から
「僕もそうです」「私もそうです」
「でも誰にも言えません」
そういったメールを
数え切れないほど頂いて
でも決して遠い所からだけじゃなくて
同じクラスメートだったり
学校の先輩・後輩からも
沢山メッセージを頂きました
10年経った今でも
もらい続けています
今となっては
「何でもっと早く言ってくれなかったの？」
「言ってくれたらよかったじゃん」と
言ってくれる人も増えました
ただ こちらからすれば
「何でそんな言えるっていうのよ？」と
小さい時からテレビをつければ
女性的な男性が「オカマ、オカマ」って
笑われて —
笑いの対象になっていて
それを見た友達だったり家族が
「嫌ね こういう人達」と言えば
自分も言ったら「嫌ね」って
言われちゃうんじゃないか
気持ち悪いと思われたどうしよう？
いじめられちゃったらどうしよう？
ハブられたらどうしよう？
そう思ったら怖くて言えませんでした
じゃあ一体いつからそうだったのか？
これも言葉で説明するより
写真で見るのが一目瞭然なので
この白い方 杉山家の
次女として生まれました
我ながら可愛かったなと
思うんですけれども
それがグローブを持ってポーズ
裃を着てポーズ
モデルガンを持ってポーズと
ご覧の通り 女の子だった時期
というのは 一度もありません
なのでスカートをはくと
途端に ―
こんな顔になっちゃいます（笑）
我ながら非常に分かりやすい
この世の終わりみたいな
顔をしているんですね
幼稚園の入園式の時には
親にスカートをはかされて
泣いて逃げまくってと
なので いつからそうだったの？
と言われれば
生まれた時からとしか
言いようがないのかなと思っています
そして ずっと女子校で
セーラー服を着て
12年間ほどルーズソックスを履いて
[学校に] 通っていたんですけれども
この時というのはですね
本当に自分だけが頭がおかしいんじゃないか？
こんな頭がおかしい人は
他にいないんじゃないか？
何で自分だけ皆と違うんだろう？
ずっと そう思っていました
ずっと女体の着ぐるみを
着たような感覚で
毎日女装しているような感覚 —
特にこの写真の頃というのは
中学生の頃ですね
二次性徴というのが始まって
身体が女性
順調に女性として
成長していく一方で
気持ちの上では
順調に男性として成長していく
まさに引き裂かれるなんていう
簡単な言葉ではすまないような 心理状況で
自分だけがおかしいんじゃないか？
いけないんじゃないか？と
本当に死んでしまいたい —
そういう風に思っていた時期も
長かったように思います
ただ ずっと根暗な毎日を
送っていたかというと そうでもなくて
女子高でスポーツもやっていて
ボーイッシュな先輩というのは
割と人気もあったりして
外では楽しく明るく
元気で ボーイッシュな
先輩を演じながら
家に帰ると一人泣いている —
そんな二重生活も長かったかなと
そんな中で１つ
大きな転機があったのは
やはりカミングアウト
というものをしました
それは仲が良かった友達に
カミングアウトをしたというよりも
せざるをえなかった
それ位 パンパンに思い詰めて
吐き出さないことには
潰れてしまいそうだった時期があって
その時に 仲の良かった友達に
話したんです
そうしたら 恐怖でしかなかった
カミングアウトなんですけれども
ずっと黙って聞いてくれていた友達が
「話してくれてありがとう
何はどうであれ 文野は文野じゃん」と
言ってくれた
僕はその時に初めて
この世に生まれ出たような
「本当の自分を言ってもいいんだ」
「人と違ってもいいんだ」という風に
思えたきっかけでした
それから すぐに全てが
上手くいったわけではないですけれど
少しずつ １人ずつ 仲の良い友達に
話して 受け入れてもらって
認めてもらうことで
自己肯定を持つことができて
少しずつ 少しずつ
そして今では そういった違いというものが
やっぱり面白いんじゃないかと
そういう風に思えるようになった
色んな考え方があるんですけど
１つ いつも自分で考えているのは
全ては こういったコップに入った
水みたいなものなんじゃないかな
という風に思っています
このコップを見た時に ある人は
「こんなに入ってるじゃん」と言うし
ある人は「これしか入ってない」と言う
けれど ここに入っているのは
量が多いとか少ないとかではなく
ある一定の量の水が入っている —
ただ その事実があるだけなんです
でもそれを これは多いんだよ
いやいや少ないよ
そういう議論は
そんなに意味があるのかなと
いつも不思議に思います
じゃあ他にどういうことか？
というと
例えば ある友達は 「いやそうは言っても
文野は女だよね ？」と言う
「いやいや何言ってんの
文野は男でしょ？」 と言う人もいる
でもそれは多分 「文野は女だよね」
と言う人にとっては 女なんだろうし
「男だよね」と言う人にとっては
男なんだろうなと
でも僕自身は身体が女子として
生まれてきて
でもずっと「僕」と思っていると
それ以外の何者でもない
それ以上でも以下でもなくて
ただ僕が僕であるという
事実でしかないという風に思っています
だから 僕のことを
「女だよね」と言う人に対して
「いや違うよ 俺は男なんだ」
と言うつもりもなくて
そう思うんならそうだろうねと
ただ僕はこう思ってるよと
そういうことで
いいんじゃないかなと
そして またもう１つ 最近では
同性婚がよく話題になっていますけれども
同性愛が善いとか 悪いとか
同性愛を認めます 認めません
そんな議論がされている
なんか ちょっと違うんじゃないかな
という風に思っていて
善いも悪いも
認めるも認めないも関係なく
ある一定数の同性愛者がいるという事実
それは変わりがないんですよね
だったら そこを議論するのは
認める認めないという話ではなくて
その事実を踏まえた上で
どういう風にして生きていけば
皆がよりよく 気持ちよく
生きていける社会になるのか
そこを しっかり
議論すべきなんじゃないかな？
そういった意味では
LGBTでも そうでない人も
とにかくどうやったら
皆が気持ちよく生きていけるのか？
考えるのがいいんじゃないかと
そんな中で 昨年の春から
こんな施設を始めてみました
『カラフルステーション』といって
１階は LGBTフレンドリーな飲食店
そして２階が LGBTフレンドリーの
コミュニティースペース
そして１、２階の壁を利用して
多様性を発信するような
ギャラリー展示を始めた —
そんな施設をやりました
今スタッフはですね
ウチのスタッフというのは
半数以上が LGBTの当事者なんですね
でも その LGBTだけではなく
LGBTの人も そうでない人も
スタッフも訪れる人も
色んな個性が輝ける —
そういった場所を
一杯 作っていけたらいいなと
いわゆるセクシュアル・
マイノリティの人というのは
夜の水商売の人 もしくは一部テレビに
出ているバラエティの世界の人
どこか遠い世界の人と
思われている人が多いんじゃないか
でも実はもっと身近にいて
すぐ隣にいる 普段生活している中にいる
そういったことを知ってもらうのが
いいんじゃないかな という思いで
こんな施設を作ってみました
これからも そういった色んな個性が
輝ける場所 そして ―
色んなカテゴリーの人が
カテゴリーを超えて 集える場所っていうのを
僕は作っていきたいなと思っています
そして皆さんに１つ
ご提案があるんですけれども
皆さんには「ウェルカミングアウト」
をして欲しいなと思います
これは何かと言いますと
当事者が
「実は僕 性同一性障害なんです」と言う
カミングアウトではなく
周りの人が「ウェルカムですよ」
という風に言って欲しい
例えば 今日の帰りに 友達に会ったり
家族に会ったりした時に
「今日 文野という人の話を聞いてね...」
と言ってもらったり
例えば ニュースで同性婚の
ニュースが流れた時に
「こういうのいいよね
日本でも進んだらいいよね」
例えばそういったように —
そういった話題をですね
肯定的に発言していただくと
すぐ隣にいるであろう
でも まだ言えていない人が
「あっ この人にだったら
言えるかもしれない」
そういう風に思う きっかけ作りに
なるんじゃないかなと
そういったことで LGBTの人も
そうでない人も
決してセクシュアリティに限らず
皆が輝けるような場所を作っていく —
一緒に彩り豊かな社会を作っていく
そんなことを皆さんと一緒に
やっていけたらいいな
という風に思っています
そして最後に これだけセクシュアリティの
話をしてきましたけれども
決してセクシュアリティのことだけを
分かってくれとか
伝えたいということではなくてですね
これはあくまで一例に過ぎないんですね
多様化する社会なんて言っても
多様化ではなく すでに社会は多様で
そういった色んな人達と
一緒に生きている
その時に 自分と違う
考え方の人とか 自分と違う人
そういった人達に
どれだけ柔軟に対応していけるか
自分の知らない世界を
いかにすぐに受け入れて 取り入れて
一緒にやっていくか？
そういうことが求められている
時代なんじゃないかなと思います
なので 今日のこのお話が
セクシュアリティに限らず
これから皆さんが色んな課題に
向き合う時の 何かの１つのきっかけ —
ヒントになったら嬉しいな
という風に思います
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）